voilà on va continuer à parler animaux
va poursuivre en parlant rester avec
vous ni nord-ouest bonjour vous êtes un
chef d'equipe à la spa de plaisir on a
entendu à la chienne labrador a été
adoptée raffinerie quatre jours ça veut
dire qu'il ya des chiens qui se font
adopter plus facilement elle est
fonction de la race du chien le
caractère le caractère digne au monde
parce que les gens qui viennent adopte
un refuge ont pas forcément tous dans
l'optique d'adopter un chien de race ok
les animaux qui peuvent partir au bout
de quelques heures bon faut qu'ils aient
vu quand même le vétérinaire bon des
fois que ça fait recours quand même
voilà l'animal arrive l'animal doit en
venant est vu par un vétérinaire il peut
nécessiter donc d'être opéré soit pour
une fracture ou alors tout simplement
une stérilisation
identification 6 et sa finesse tous les
animaux qui sont adoptés sont stérilisés
alors la plupart du temps oui on essaye
de faire les siennes obligatoirement
pour éviter les problèmes des chaleurs
qui peuvent occasionner des tumeurs
mammaires à lorsqu'un animal vie et puis
c'est aussi une question d'éthique pour
éviter justement toutes les portes et
qui ne sont pas assumés et qui abreuvent
les airs fut justement cette période de
l'année d'attaquant quand le petit chat
qu'on a vu tania elle elle cherche
toujours alors elle va très bien elle
est adorable on espère bien la place et
celui qu'un gros lance un petit appel
parce que ce week-end effectivement vous
venez de le dire ce sont les journées
portes ouvertes à la spa de plaisir
samedi dimanche et des horaires
allergies élargi par dont 10 heures 10
heures 18 heures comment ça se passe des
journées portes ouvertes par ces
beaucoup d'actes nettoyez bien vos
animaux pour qu'il soit voilà aussi qui
on a une équipe de bénévoles et on
propose en général à côté de ça on
essaye de collecter aussi d'aider font
donc c'est l'occasion d'organiser des de
l'artisanat qui est fabriqué donc par
les bénévoles vendus au profit des
animaux donc c'est un don pour pour la
spa est aussi un coin buvette donc ça
permet aussi d'apporter une animation en
plus d adoption puisque le terme pas
ouvertes justement porte bien son nom
puisque là les gens peuvent venir pour
découvrir ce qu'est un refuge et on est
là aussi pour les randonnées le mode de
fonctionnement
alors je vais donner quelques chiffres
du coup puisque vous dites comment
organiser un refuge à se faire plaisir a
ouvert ses portes et à peu près une
vingtaine d'années oui un petit peu plus
près de sept ans ah oui comme 7 ans
parce que
il vient entre 80 et 81 80 90 chiens
s'en charger et puis des animaux que moi
j'appelle atypique mais vous dirais que
c'est pas atypique c'est derrière et pas
mal de rongeurs mais lorsque vous avez
aussi des poissons rouges voilà on adore
ça nous arrive aux toits demande avant
les animaux qui sont là en attente d'une
décision bon le les poissons rouges sont
arrivés avec d'autres animaux bien sûr
d'accord et plus encore un chiffre qu'un
c'est le nombre de salariés que compte
le site
en comptant les vétérinaires les agents
d'accueil les assistant vétérinaire est
donc responsable il ya donc
effectivement les agents animaliers qui
sont là pour s'occuper des animaux est
placée bien sûr il ya des bénévoles oui
la chance d'avoir un poster des
bénévoles car justement à être là sans
le chien oui alors essentiellement c'est
l'image qu'on a des bénévoles de
promener les chiens ce qui est très
important parce que ça permet aux
animaux de côtoyer d'autres personnes et
du coup d'être toujours stimulé et
d'être sorti le travail des agents
animaliers permet pas forcément de
d'aller promener les chiens voilà c'est
pas notre principal travail même pas du
tout n'a rarement le temps
malheureusement et les bénévoles sont là
aussi pour aider au nettoyage on peut
avoir besoin en période de grande
affluence d'animaux dead parce qu'il ya
cette période peut avoir plus de soins à
donner aux animaux donc les bénévoles
sont là pour nous aider aussi pour le
nettoyage peut être bénévole ce qui est
une formation nécessaire alors certes on
essaie sans évidemment fois mais les
amis bien sûr mais finalement ça peut ne
pas suffire malheureusement dans le sens
où c'est pas toujours facile
et puis battre avec les animaux c'est
beaucoup de nettoyage donc faut être
conscient de ça aussi et respecter
respecter des règles pour promener les
chiens éviter que les animaux puissent
se battre se sauvaient également un chat
sa griffe aussi donc il faut expliquer
tout ça donc les bénévoles sont là aussi
pour pour être pour organiser aussi vers
de manifestations des stands on organise
aussi plusieurs fois par an maintenant
un canicross donc voilà c'est des
activités annexes des collectes
alimentaires également qui sont faites
vous en offrir le jour de bénévoles
toutes les bonnes volontés sont les
bienvenues
sauvé bienvenu bien sûr bien sûr
d'accord vous parlez de à l'occasion de
ces journées portes ouvertes vous allez
organiser plusieurs manifestations pour
collecter des fonds du coup je rebondis
sur sur ce que vous disiez comment
fonctionne financièrement une refuge
comme le vôtre un loisir est ce que
c'est vous avez des subventions ou
est-ce que vous fonctionner en autonomie
fidèle à la partie parce que c'est ça
c'est ça c'est les dons et legs 1 qui
permettent à la spa de sauver les
animaux tout tout tout le temps et de et
de financer ma le fonctionnement des
refuges qui à l'alimentation des animaux
mais également les les soins
vétérinaires les médicaments sont reçoit
beaucoup d'animaux mauvais état qu'ils
peuvent arriver de fourrière avec bon il
ya aussi des maladies les épidémies pour
les animaux trouvés non vaccinés donc ça
nécessite beaucoup de beaucoup de
subventions du
public voilà pour la lah l'activité
refuge voilà c'est pour ça que la
s-class sollicite régulièrement les gens
pour pour donner je me suis
effectivement vraiment beaucoup besoin
je reviens sur ce journée portes
ouvertes 1 je le rappelle samedi et
dimanche 10h 18h la spa de plaisir
combien ça coûte d'adopter un chien un
chat ou un poisson rouge orangé pour
adopter peut pas même vous allez c'est
pas forcément si les mêmes les mêmes
soins enfin le les mêmes les mêmes soins
à tatouages et c'est donc pour un chat
on demande une participation 80 euros
pour un chien de mon une participation
de 130 euros et pour une chaîne 150
euros ça comprend donc la stérilisation
des animaux leur identification qui est
obligatoire et leur vaccination
également presque voulant mettre une
petite fille entité est que ces animaux
sur leur caractère par exemple parce
qu'on allait le voir des familles qui
viennent avec des enfants bien sûr une
race de chien dont on se doute que c'est
pas tellement compatible avec des
enfants il y avait chez qui ont besoin
de calme donc quand vous en doutez
normalement d'activités dont peut-être
pas les mettre dans un petit studio tout
à fait où il faut pouvoir s'adapter et à
l'animal que l'on doit placer et aux
gens qui ont une idée précise en tête ou
un certain contexte de vie a proposé à
l'animal donc effectivement c'est le
travail des agents animaliers de pouvoir
conseiller c'est vraiment un travail de
conseil aussi d'orienter les gens dans
leurs choix quelquefois les gens peuvent
avoir à l'esprit bon on va prendre un
chiot mais oui mais on est dans un petit
appartement on travaille beaucoup et et
toute la partie éducation les gens n'ont
pas forcément à l'esprit donc
quelquefois il peut être plus
raisonnable un animal adultes déjà
éduqué s'agit en plus on assure un suivi
on propose des cours d'éducation
gratuite suite à l'adoption pour aider
les gens qui peuvent rencontrer quelques
difficultés
ça peut se concevoir les mâles qui
arrivent a besoin de s'adapter dans son
nouvel environnement tous les gens
prennent adopte un chien un chat qu'avec
des histoires de vie qui sont
certainement pas simple non plus alors
bien sûr il ya des mots que quelqu'un
doit ni mot quelque part abandonné donc
abandonné donc quelque part traumatisé
la plupart des animaux il faut savoir
que les aliments une grande capacité de
réadaptation s'en rend compte
et puis quelques fois on peut avoir des
chiens beaucoup plus craintifs qui vont
a besoin d'être sociabiliser donc là
effectivement dans ces cas là il faut un
environnement calme des gens patients et
qu'ils ont peut-être aussi une certaine
expérience y aurait évité des déceptions
le posteriori des adoptants parce que
les gens peuvent adopter un chien tout
plus d'une semaine selon roland hoff
c'est beaucoup de contraintes un animal
parce que c'est aussi laissé du plaisir
mais c'est aussi de la contrainte
aussi ces voix là on doit le dire et le
répéter bon quand c'est le cas quand les
gens se rendent compte qu'ils faire une
erreur ou prendre une décision un peu
rapide adoptant bon les gens
se retrouvent quelquefois dans de rares
cas heureusement à ramener l'animal
alors que nous on a monté c'était aussi
notre travail de leur expliquer ce à
quoi il fallait s'attendre le fait de
proposer des cours d'éducation ça permet
de régler des petits soucis rencontrés
au départ et les gens les gens justement
se sentant et des conseillers peuvent
comme ça grave hier certaines petites
étapes à franchir
d'accord donc je rappelle ses journées
portes ouvertes ces samedi et dimanche
10h 18h à la spa de plaisir j'avais une
dernière question en ces temps de crise
malheureusement est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que le nombre d'abandons
d'animaux augmente parce que les gens
c'est pas qu'ils ne veulent pas mais que
certains ne peuvent plus entretenir un
animal alors oui malheureusement les
confronter plus en plus à des situations
difficiles et le problème c'est que sont
là on arrive dans une période où il n'y
a pas forcément plus d'abandons une
liées aux vacances mais il ya moins de
place dans les refuges puisque c'est une
période sans adoption donc du coup on se
retrouve déjà confrontés à des
situations les gens n'ont pas d'autres
possibilités et on sait qu'on est là
pour ça malheureusement les gens qui
abandonnent un animal pour un oui pour
un non
comble par dans les refuges et
malheureusement on est obligés
quelquefois de mettre des en attente des
gens qui ont un besoin urgent de confier
leur animal et kim des conditions très
compliquées derrière décidé grave
situation sociale effectivement là vous
le ressentez aussi l'effet crise à
l'aspect aussi alors aussi mais
heureusement les adoptions ne dénie
diminue pas tant mieux donc voilà on
voit bien que les gens sont beaucoup
plus soucieux des coûts éventuels
vétérinaire et ça effectivement il faut
être conscient que un animal c'est un
investissement aussi qu'il faut prévoir
de pouvoir assurer subvenir à ses
besoins et en cas de maladie également
mais bon les légendes en lançant
continuer à adopter massivement et
heureusement et on en attend nombreux ce
week end d'accord très bien donc ce
week-end c'est samedi et dimanche à
l'espace plaisir de 10h 18h merci
beaucoup d'être